oh oh thank you
kathy had it
okay
i won't lose that one
okay it's 11 o'clock
i'll
call the work session to order
and um
uh turn our attention to uh sb 401
i think
i think this should uh
go relatively easily since
we're just looking at the amendment
which um
[Music]
which replaces everything other than the
um
opening statement
which is where the the money is um
appropriated
so
i think we've had plenty of discussion
on these um
bridges and roads and dash cams and
that would cause an issue
so if i could uh
i would like to have a motion to accept
amendment
1844 h
thank you oops we need somebody to
excuse us two of our
members are
in the redistricting
committee meetings so
i can't believe they thought that was
more important
because they are also executing their
things today okay so i have a motion by
representative petry
is there any further any discussion
no
oh wait this is we're just accepting the
amendment yeah just okay
all in favor of the amendment
thank you
okay now
i need an otpa
on sb 401
thank you joe
thank you represent heath
yes
share the vote is five to nothing on
most um
as amended on hb
sp 401
okay thank you very much and uh i
appreciate all the work that d.o.t
has put into this and
our our budget analysts
um mickey landrigan has put into this
and uh i think we've got a better bill
and i think that we have um
we'll have happier con constituents out
there in
the rhoden bridge area so thank you very
much
okay
now we turn to
381 sb 381
dealing with the um
and
uh
we did have a reconsideration
motion yesterday
the current
status of this is itl
six to one
and uh the reason
that
the vote was this way is because
in our opinion we had
two offices trying to accomplish the
same thing
and um that was
that's not something i could allow to
happen
so if i understand correctly uh senator
reagan
the
whoever they are legislative office
services
ols
yeah thanks
um
is in the process of drafting an
amendment and so would you come forward
and tell us what you're doing
i did pass out
the
rsa that deals with this
so
uh good morning madam chair members of
house finance
uh the objection
two agencies being tasked with
um
oversight of education
purposes
so the amendment
will remove the two references
in the office of the child
advocate to
education and education records
and also as there was an oversight as to
who the appointing authority was and
it was added into the amendment that the
appointment will be by the governor with
the approval of the council
okay
and uh just so everyone knows um
that
the first reference is 21v colon 2
c
if you like
my copy has yellow on it but the yellow
didn't the coffee
and the other reference is in
21v colon 4
8.
so we will see this amendment
uh
in
our exact session
yes okay thank you
now if i that that's i appreciate it
thank you
you can stay there or not but
are there any questions that anybody has
for senator reagan
yep go ahead thank you madam chair so as
far as
um any
fiscal note um for this particular bill
it's still the same
appropriating 500 000 to get this office
up and running that's correct thank you
okay
representative heath
thank you ma'am cheer um
will this advocate for special education
now be housed under the advocates office
child advocates office
it will remain separate
it will remain separate in a separate
location
department of administrative services
appreciates
what a conflict that would be
so
and
once this is signed off they have office
space for us
thank you
representative petrie
thank you madam chair uh thank you for
taking my question
uh as far as privacy now is is it up to
the parents whether the advocate gets
involved
in other words
access to records and whatever
or
the
the record of special education that is
awaiting a performance audit now
um
is
by testimony it was just so dismal that
i expect the advocate to be advocating
actively
with the school districts
who are denying services for
specious reasons
so they'll be basically able to subpoena
if you want to use the world yes in
other words they and now the parents
with the parents permission or how to
how does that
now they're they're
they're there to see to the special
education needs
of children okay so if they see a
problem in or or if a problem is
reported right right exactly right thank
you
okay
thank you appreciate it
and
i'd like to ask the um
office of child advocacy if you'd come
forward
i'm sorry i have not met you before
good morning good night sanchez child
advocate what first name cassandra jess
okay pleasure to meet you
well thank you for having me here
welcome uh welcome to uh
the
office of child advocacy thank you and
uh
it's a interesting office
so
uh
i know that in your testimony
that you had indicated or your whether
it was you or someone else
had indicated that um
was charged with this
special education problem
we do have jurisdiction over education
as well correct yes and that was updated
in december 2020. okay so
does your office have any great problem
if we remove that from your office yes
we do
the main issue with that is that we do
serve children
in all aspects and
i know that there has been discussion
around us specifically working with
children
involved in the juvenile justice system
involved with dcyf which yes that is one
aspect of what we do and an important
aspect of ensuring all children across
the state are serviced appropriately we
do need to be able to have access to
their education records as well that is
part of the whole child and we look at
so
[Music]
these two offices could certainly work
together
they could um i think there's a lot of
concern around that in the current
office for myself specifically
it is confusing already the systems that
are in place in regards to education for
families and to navigate a system where
we could be working in one respect and
another office could be potentially
duplicating that or working in a
different respect on
in regards to the same family can be
quite confusing so we'd like to reduce
that if possible we do feel that having
the specialty within the office could
serve the need and meet the needs of the
families we are at no point denying that
there is a need for a special education
advocate and there is a need for the
specialty within our office but we do
feel it's best served communication wise
and to be a clear office under one roof
okay
are there any questions from anybody
else
representative heath thank you madam
chair so you are advocating that the
special education advocate be housed
and um work in conjunction with your
office
yes so we have responded to the bill
that
we are
we are in support to a degree but we are
not in support of this being a separate
office so we have provided um a finance
financial write-up of what it would cost
to add this
this role to our office versus the
financial note of having a separate
independent office right thank you yes
okay i do have a couple of just
follow-up questions that
yes
if i
understand what i'm hearing from many
people
they don't believe
right wrong or indifferent
that
your office has been um
successful
in resolving problems
that
families have
and
um
is it because
you're tasked with
is it because you're overwhelmed
or is it some other reason
i i think that's a complex question
yes i know i know um and and so i think
there's a couple of answers to that um i
think we've been clear that when it
comes specifically to special education
we don't have the resources in the
office to meet that need right now so
that is a big piece of it is having the
resources available within the office
i think as well um some
a piece of this bill
that i've been concerned about all along
is what is the expectation what do
families truly believe the advocate can
do we do not have authority to override
iep decisions
we do have the ability to educate
families
to help them work through the process to
make sure that they understand the
process and are taking the steps
necessary to be able to meet their
child's needs but
by no way is this advocate position even
if it is an independent office is this
position going to be attending iep
meetings with every single family are
they going to be overriding decisions
that are being made so
my concern is is that
families are believing that that is
what's going to happen
with this bill and
our office does not have the ability to
do that we can make recommendations to
to school systems to the department of
education on better ways to to manage
some issues when we have specific
complaints about a family we can do a
deeper investigation into where the
system failed that family and make those
recommendations but no office of special
education advocate or of the child
advocate has the authority to override
decisions that are made
okay
um
i'm thinking
i i don't wanna i don't wanna say
something that's uh that's wrong
um
i guess from my perspective
at this point
that
i would prefer
to not
put
this advocate
into your office
if we find
within the next
couple of years
that we're having
problems with this
you know the the two offices not
being able to work together or
you know if it isn't working or whoever
is appointed the advocate isn't working
then i think that um
we could legislatively
certainly
the
special education committee
is a special education
people
are
i don't even know what
word to use are totally opposed if
that's the right term
to
this office going into
your office at this time
i don't know how many emails i've
received or
comments or
attacks in the hall
or whatever
from my from my perspective
i think that it's probably the best
thing to do right now
is to set up a separate office
and
[Music]
we'll work just make sure that
whoever is
appointed
understands
that one of their responsibilities
is working with you because that is
i think that's
very very important
you can't
you cannot do your job or your advocacy
i guess is is what that is i
i don't like advocates but that's okay
that's just me
um
but that's that's sort of how
from uh represent buco thank you madam
chair i just have a question in regards
to this performance audit
excuse me is there a performance order
going on now and if so when will it's
going to be completed it has not begun
we uh it will be
brought to fiscal
this month
or may may 15th may whatever the date is
for
uh approval thank you thank you
some heath
thank you madam chair
i disagree with you um respectfully i i
believe all right
i just um
special ed is fraught
with
difficulties
um
i used to be a special ed teacher
special administrator worked at the
department of education and in
before i was deputy commissioner i had
special ed was my field
um
it's a
it's a personal situation it's hard and
difficult
um
your office
i applaud because you
in you're new to your role first of all
so i i
back away from casting any judgment on
your office because you're new
and
i believe that the former advocate
knew she needed extra help
and for me
the special ed advocate would be
a wonderful
asset in your office because so many of
the issues are a stem in special
education
so
my feeling is that i would like to see
work together
and and come up with a great plan
of of how to work better with school
districts and the department of ed
because
there's a lot going on in special ed
there are a lot of new changes there are
a lot of new laws
the funding is is at the local level is
always difficult
and i just i would feel better
with one office working together um to
address these issues i just think it's
it would be a coordinated effort and
more powerful
that's my
feeling
thank you that's fine um
for the two reps that
just came in
um i just wanted to let you know that
amendment passed
um
representative or sorry
senator reagan
has
an amendment that is currently being
provided
at ols
or written at ols
and it
21v4
which you have there
yeah
21v4
yeah and i'm sorry
and 21
v2
and that is to
take
education
responsibilities
out of
the um
child advocate office
okay
and that's
we and
um
i'm sorry cassandra
sanchez yes okay
and uh cassandra sanchez is currently
the appointed um child advocate
she's taken over what two months ago
two and a half weeks ago
okay
the
people
uh do not want the special education
advocate in this office
for
a variety of reasons
and miss sanchez is here now
talking about why
it should remain within
the
office of child advocate
so
that's i think
where we are
okay and
yeah
and um
i know that we uh
won't be able to vote on this because we
don't have the amendments
but i just want to make sure
that we have a
good airing and understanding
because
it is it's important
so just quick question i'm assuming this
hearing just got in the way and ms
sanchez was your first
to test no um
senator reagan introduced what he was
going to um okay put in the uh in what i
assume we will be hearing from other
individuals
well i don't know
you know i don't you know the the issue
is
the issue was that i had
two offices
that
okay
and so what this does is take what the
amendment will do
is take that responsibility away from
child advocate
and put it into the special ed thing
so
that allows for two offices
and ms sanchez is arguing against that
and that's uh certainly if i may
i'm just happy we're doing the advocate
because i think we need to do that um
and i'm not gonna
get stuck on one office or another um
if somehow within the amendment we could
um
get in coordination
um so that we know there is um
that you folks will be working together
my preference would be
the one office
because i think advocate
says a lot
but
certainly um i can live with either way
i think the important thing is the
advocate position and i'm happy to
support that so i am flexible
i am also flexible
in my
position are there any other questions
yes uh reps and uh thank you madam chair
um i'm just
trying really hard to suss out you know
the right thing to do
and um they're just things in my head
that i guess i'd like to put out there
for other discussion or to
people to help me to understand um the
first is uh mr sanchez is new in this
and so it's hard to predict what's going
to what that office is going to look
like going forward and some of the
issues that occurred in the previous
situation may not pertain so there's
part of me that would like to see more
coordination uh with the two and there's
some sense in my head that this
would fit well under there um but again
with miss sanchez being new to the
position we don't know what that's going
to look like i also look back you know
we their first um
suggestion was to put an interim study
which we said no and then we moved to
itl the whole thing and now we're back
to passing the whole thing and i'm just
feeling a little
lost and a little bewildered about how
we've gone from interim study to itl to
now this should be a good thing and
where should it lay
well
the itl was because we had
it we had
okay
that
were trying to do the same thing
that was what the itl was all about time
to understand that with the amendment
pulling education out of the child
advocates office and special ed becoming
a separate um because i also
it seems to me you know i can be fine
with that but it seems to me that part
of advocacy in with children kind of
involves education
so i have a hard time understanding the
limit of the child advocacy office if
that office doesn't have to do with
education that kind of
limits significantly what they would be
doing
maybe ms sanchez can speak a little bit
to that but i feel it's a little
confusing to me that would have a child
advocate office that does not deal with
education
go ahead yes so that is a main concern
of mine we do treat as a as i mentioned
prior we do treat the holistic view of
the child which encompasses their
education um their leisure activities
their mental health their physical
health so as of right now in in the
purpose of the extension of our
jurisdiction in december 2020 was for
that very purpose because we saw those
limitations and we had those limitations
and we were not able to do to treat the
whole child and to help advocate for the
whole child when those limitations were
set so it would be highly concerning
that we would not have the ability to
access necessary records for children
and i had mentioned that
there is an understanding that our scope
covers
children in dcyf custody children
involved with the dcyf system children
involved in juvenile justice but i have
understood yes i've only been here for
two and a half weeks and in my two and a
half weeks the first thing that has
jumped out at me is the fact that there
is a lot of education to be done on what
our office can and should be doing
i absolutely have it in my agenda to be
able to reach out to school districts to
connect with them to connect with the
department of education as one of the
primary
roles is stepping in
i understand that that has not been
built up yet and that relationship is
extremely important to be able to do the
work that we know is a limitation of our
office that was highlighted during the
strategic planning within our office and
that was something that was asked of me
coming in if i was willing to take on
and i would like to be have the
opportunity to take that on and i i do
believe that
that our it will be
setting back our entire office and the
work that they how far they have come
we've only been here for four years and
there has a lot of work been work that
has been done within those four years
and this will greatly set us back on
that work
madam chair
yes could someone speak to the other
side of that certainly
okay senator reagan
in the creation of the come up come up
do you have any further questions oh
we'll be back with you
in the creation of
sb 381
mention was made of the office of the
proved
that
that was not something that they did
that they were active in or had any
successes in
and so we never thought about it
in the same area
until
at a
later hearing
all of a sudden appears the oca to say
well we already do this when we already
so
that's the reason why and every
reasoned person who has reviewed this
has agreed that this should be in a
separate place
with us it has a separate purpose
so the office of the child advocate was
created because of children that were in
danger
and we thought this was
a way to
mitigate the problems with children who
are in danger
the special education is a whole other
world
it's a whole different area of
service to children
they're not the same because they both
say advocate
they're entirely separate
areas
and i can understand that
it became obvious that the office of the
child advocate
was eager to get their hands on the
money proposed in the special education
advocate
and add positions
but that's just
in a management term it's empire
building
so
they're not in any conflict
and i don't believe there's anything
lost by them each doing their separate
missions
and they should go about doing what they
were intended to do
and we expect that this special
delve deeper into
the problems that we have with special
education
so
the
i don't have the binder with me now but
there's a four inch binder at the
performance audit and oversight
committee with testimony
and i could say
in that whole four inch binder and it's
full of testimony there's not a happy
so
the child advocate had they wanted to
had the opportunity to do it they just
okay
uh
okay thank you senator oh yes you may
thank you
just uh just to make it a little more
confusing in the beginning of this
bill here
it says that the
advocate will be attached to the
department of administrative services
right that was an attempt at neutrality
thank you
and that's not that's not an unusual
thing as a matter of fact the office of
okay so it's and that seems to be the
they attach them
no responsibility
for them other than to find a other than
to find a place for them to um
surely
so senator thank you for taking my
question i guess that i want to make
sure that i'm understanding your
position if i understand it
the um
you you agree that there should be a an
uh an advocate for special education but
it should not fall within the
jurisdiction of the
uh
rsa21v right
and and but that advocate for special
education should also be housed in the
department of administrative services
it it's wherever the ais can find office
space
that's okay
so okay
so i i guess i'm sure if i can't ask to
follow so i guess i'm
sorry you already are so i guess i'm
logically it would seem since one is in
the office of administrative services
you know for neutrality reasons as you
say which may make sense the office of
the child special of the special
education advocates should be in
administrative services and i'm just
wondering if we have
you know
if we have both of them in there
wouldn't it be more efficient really to
just have one one uh
office doing
you know doing gold let me just make a
comment okay
when it says it's um
assigned to das it's only for
administrative purposes in other words
it's
finding them a place a room
getting them a telephone
they may be located in um transportation
because that's who has the space
or safety or someplace they won't share
an office yeah they won't share an
office
so oh go ahead no i'm so gonna say but i
mean if they're
i guess
if somebody isn't doing
whether it's in in the uh in the um
uh office of the uh of the 21v
child advocate or the special education
child advocate
who
i mean who's their supervisor who who
who decides you know if they're doing
their job or not doing their job the
governor
so the governor is the supervisor of
both of them
in the end
supervisor of all the executive agencies
yeah so okay all right
okay thank you
miss sanchez i believe uh represent
turcotte has a couple of questions for
you
and if i may i would like to address the
supervision as well that's possible
so we have an oversight commission
that works to oversee and to ensure that
we are meeting our mandate so ultimately
yes the governor appoints the position
but there is a separate oversight
commission that is in place to ensure we
are meeting our mandate
and so my
my guess if this was created as a new
office there would need to be a new
oversight commission for that office as
well
thank you thank you
representative thank you madam chair
thanks for taking the question um i
believe i know you're fairly new in the
position but i heard
could you either elaborate or repeat the
comments you made
about
sounded to me like you were admitting
that the current
office of the child advocate has been
what you're supposed to be doing did i
hear that correctly
so
if
i can start from the beginning um so we
we received this new jurisdiction in
december 2020.
um within that time frame we were also
within the strategic planning process so
the prior child advocate along with the
oversight commission and outside
stakeholders
went through the strategic planning
process to see what pieces of the
mandate they were meeting what they
would like for goals for the future
and what parts of the mandate they were
not meeting the pieces of the mandate
that they were not meeting were in
regards to this newer jurisdiction but
the office had existed without that
jurisdiction for some time so the focus
was really at that point
unfortunately
in the middle of a pandemic was
developing
this aspect of the jurisdiction which
includes special education so it was
understood at that time of strategic
planning which it is now that that was a
shortcoming of the office that that was
an area of focus for the future of the
office to build that up since that had
not been
achieved thus far by the office so i
inherited the office with that being a
primary goal to build the relationships
of the department of education to
outreach communities school districts
superintendent's offices so that
families understood this role in our
jurisdiction because that was the other
missing piece was that families were not
aware
that we had oversight and education that
we could assist with special education
so it was it's getting out informing the
public informing the community meeting
with families and ensuring that they
know they can call our office file a
complaint and we will look into
whether the department of education is
meeting
their guidelines for this family and
then to be able to follow up with the
department of education and
through relationship building make
recommendations for them to make
improvements on behalf of these families
and that is something that i have taken
on
and am very willing to do with this
thank you thank you
um
so if this new office
of the advent kit for special education
um
would you be able to accomplish that
with current staffing or would that
require you adding additional staff and
whatever
yeah so that was something else that was
found within the strategic planning was
that the resources in the office do not
have the specialty for special education
so we would be looking to add to the
office which is what we provided um in
in a letter that i sent you which would
be the finance for adding the position
to the office and we would look to add
specifically a staff member with special
education law background
because that that in itself we have
learned throughout the community that
special education law is very convoluted
and it takes a specialty to understand
parents rights within that so we would
be looking to add that as well as
a support staff for that
special education advocate who has that
law background
yes
are there any further questions for ms
sanchez
okay
is there thank you thank you yep just
we really enjoy meeting you this morning
and uh thank you i appreciate your time
probably wouldn't have the opportunity
if this bill wasn't here
uh
representative cordelli
we're gonna focus on
what we're focusing on
most definitely okay thank you thank you
uh glenn cordelli representing
tuftonboro molten baron sandwich in the
first of all i i think it would be bad
policy
to mix
special education services in with an
office that is
i'll say centered on
dcyf and juvenile justice
secondly
we've heard discussion about
jurisdiction
and i'd point you to the office of child
advocate
21 v section
and if you look at the definitions
agency means any department institution
bureau or office of the state
child or youth talks about a custody
or receiving services from
the division
division is divined defined as the
department of health and human services
or the division of children youth and
families
there's no magic
you know you can argue about whether
there's jurisdiction over the department
of education
um and i think that the attorney general
has said that they do
in my discussions with the lawyer for
the department of education
but i'd point out
that the department of education
provides no direct services to children
it's all done at the local level local
school districts provide those services
those special education services
so i see nowhere in here
that the office of the child advocate
would have the ability or the authority
to go
into the local school district level
their responsibility is at the state
department level
so in terms of jurisdiction i think that
there would be no jurisdiction for the
current office of the child advocate
advocate to get into the area of special
needs
services provided
represent turka thank you madam chair
thank you representative cordelli for
taking the question uh you were in the
room when miss sanchez just talked about
for lack of a better word specialist to
handle because it's so much different do
you agree that the
there's a large difference between the
office of the child advocacy and what
this bill is proposing
uh yes i would
and i think
representative heath
previously mentioned that
special education services is a unique
and difficult area and certainly
requires
specialized um
knowledge and information um
about both federal and state law
and the
child advocate as has said um they do
not have that expertise right now in
their office and would have to hire
follow-up thank you madam chair um
thanks for the additional question so
would it be your
your position that
um
having the two separate
now i don't want to call them
departments but whatever it would be
called the two different advocacy groups
since money would have to be spent
either way to develop this
new department
whether or not it's placed under here
or as its own in a department that's
more specialized for the purpose
if the money's going to be required
either way
is it your position that it's better to
segregate it into its own
department
most definitely i think
definitely it needs to be its own
separate office um and within the office
except me under the jurisdiction of the
department of administrative services
who uh it is my understanding would
preserve a
pro
provide services such as payroll and
things like that um would come from uh
department of administrative services
that's why these types of offices are
placed there
okay is there anyone else that wants to
talk about this mary uh represent heath
um you had a question yes i do um thank
you sorry
special education has a process and if a
complaint is filed at the department of
ed there's a number of things that can
happen and it rises to various levels
where in that interaction would you see
the
special education advocate
provides certain duties for
the proposed new office
similar in many regards to the
responsibilities in the current child
advocate office
in terms of
receiving complaints and investigation
and so forth
i would see that
the
office of
advocate for special needs would work
with the department
if they found problems and so forth
just like the office of child advocate
they have
wouldn't have no ability to overturn
the findings of an iep team at the local
district level
but would be able to look and see if
there are patterns
of problems
being at the district level or
throughout the state amongst districts
as to
problems in the processes and recommend
solutions
and i think the
the outline of functionality for the
office
is a starting place and we can see
as the office develops
you know what
revisions
may be
required
and other functionality added to the
office
to ensure that
parents needs are being met
just follow up
certainly in relation to
the uh mandates that come from idea and
our own state plan
uh yes
yeah i would definitely see that they
would be always up to date on changes to
idea or
thank you representative cordelli thank
you
is there anyone else that wants to say
something
remember you for hearing me
kate shea from goffstown
okay so who am i
i'm an advocate volunteer advocate in
the state for kids with autism kids with
special needs i have four children of my
own
and i am very proud we are talking only
about
381 no
no
whether this office should be separate
or it should be under
the
sure uh child advocate sure okay okay we
we don't i mean i know you have a story
and that's wonderful but
but we that's not what we're here for
sure thank you
okay so in terms of distinguishing this
from being part of the child advocates
office i think we've already heard with
testimony that was previous and i'm
hoping that you all had access to that
testimony
we've come up a number of times many of
us that are parents who work jobs who
have these kids with special needs we've
provided a plethora of this evidence as
to why this needs to be distinguished so
i'm hoping that you receive that i did
send some of that to you we have some 90
pages of a 700 person petition that was
signed
there's one reason right there this
needs to be different
many of us have had encounters working
with some of these agencies state
agencies who have no knowledge of things
on the ground level so you just heard a
little bit from senator uh
representative cardelli about
um that this is something at the
district level okay so there's a very
intensive process that we go through um
as parents to understand what this
process is and that's part of what led
us here
um i would beg this committee to ask
some of those specific questions i'm in
software engineering i work with
executives i go into meetings all the
time asking for funding i would never
dream of going in asking for funding
without understanding anything about
this process so i would like to leave
that with you all today
so
so first of all knowledge is a problem
area okay
expertise we've heard of that before
from others
um i beg to ask the question if this
person even understands what proficiency
scores are for special education in new
hampshire for our kids 36 000 of them
that have ieps these are regular kids
okay non-ieps iep children are in single
digits
what we're after okay i
all this plays into that well we all
underst well
most of us have a really good
understanding of special ed and what the
problems are great because that's one of
the areas that we fund
in the budget so we have asked i think
in the world so may i ask you a question
have you attended an iep meeting ever
yes as a matter of fact yes how many
so we're one like i said we're
we're familiar with it so so it needs to
be separate because we already have pic
we already have the we already have the
dra we already have all of these empires
that have grown in mushrooms and we got
here today because we need something
different okay reason why i bring up
software engineering is when we have a
defect in that life cycle we fix it
early and often we don't let it
propagate to just add on more
bureaucracy is not going to fix that
defect problem here so we need to do
something radically different and when i
testified last time to that house
committee i said
i i would be you know quite all right
with hiring a consultant out of nowhere
hire somebody that's going to do some
something radically different for this
state because the situation we're
finding ourselves in is we continue to
mushroom it's not going to matter if
we're spending 500 000 we're going to be
facing class action lawsuits against the
state of new hampshire
from the parents and the concerned
parties in the state who did do it in
texas and they'll do it here too so i
would hope that that should be something
we're paying attention to also we need
to do something radically different in
this case we need to test and learn and
not do the same stuff all over again
that's my rationale for doing something
different okay thank you thank you just
a moment
someone may have a question
and thank you for
stopping keeping it focused
representative madam chair so is it your
position that you believe these two
offices should be separate and not
together yes or no
yes thank you you're welcome
representative buko uh thank you madam
chair
it seems like we're pretty deep into the
policy here um
the only financing that i see in this
bill is the five hundred thousand to
establish the office
and my in my office
only because the amendment that we will
be looking at this afternoon
removes the
child advocate from
well it sets up a separate office
and removes responsibility for education
from the office of child advocate that's
why it sounds like we're into a lot of
policy issues
but that's
that's
that was
that was the reason why we idled it in
the first place and and
and if i may follow up how did that come
to us
from the from the policy committee
did they pass this it came to us from
the policy committee as a separate
organization
all right
thank you very much okay
um
any other
comments would you like
tell us tell us who you are
hi i'm darlene gildersleeve
i am the parent of two children who have
ieps
who suffer tremendously under the school
districts of hopkinton new hampshire and
hooksett new hampshire
one district was so horrific that okay i
actually moved please
oh i'm just telling you i know we don't
we don't need your story
okay that's not our that's not our
responsibility that was your
responsibility when you talk to the
education committee what we want to know
is
which way to go oh absolutely um just so
you know i'm in for full disclosure i'm
a recent board member of the
disabilities rights center i'm also
extensively trained in special education
law
and a graduate of the unh institute on
disability leadership series
wrap around training for mental health
extensive state committees on the
10-year mental health plan etc
i have been volunteering to help
families for 10 years
and as such i highly
advocate for the office of the special
education advocate to be separate
i myself have called
with many other parents i have called
the former child advocate begging for
help for my children but also for
children that i've helped in rochester
whose families are obligated to sign a
non-disclosure agreement by the law firm
of drummond and woodson with their
lobbyist jerry zellen
gagging parents under ndas
so that they can't share their story
without threat of lawsuit
this is what's going on in education in
new hampshire our own taxpayer dollars
hold on okay i'll i'll
last
our own taxpayer dollars that we pay
are then paid to these highly paid law
firms wildly star and peter peters i
think anne drummond and whitson to fight
against our kids with disabilities so
how does that affect who
so the yeah so that's okay whether this
must be it must be separate because many
parents and myself have called a child
child advocate they do zilch nothing
with education particularly nothing with
special education
okay so it must be separate for any
change to be done in new hampshire
i really appreciate it thank you so much
and again i don't you know i'm not
cutting you off but
i can take questions but i really want
to focus on what our
discussion is all about
okay uh
yes you may ask a question i i
appreciate it thank you very much for
taking the question and i appreciate
believe me i appreciate your you know
it's obviously you're very frustrated
and i completely understand that
the thing i i guess i'm a little bit
concerned about is this and both you and
the prior witness testified about this
you've sort of said
given the picture that you know the
school districts are not sort of doing
their job they're not handling these
things the way they should be and and i
think your witness would testify before
you said and there's a there's a whole
lot of other people that have tried to
get involved and they're not doing it
either
i guess that what the question that that
raises to me is
how do we know that this you know we're
going to form a new
uh sort of inspector general for a lack
of a better term
for special education
how do we know they're going to do their
job either if all these other
places aren't doing their job why should
who are you know state or local
officials that are
you know presumably well intentioned how
do we know that this agency is going to
be the
the magic one that will do the job greg
thank you for your question
because firstly
families and the students are going to
come first for the first time in
education history of new hampshire the
lobbyists the unions these hardly paid
law firms they're not going to have any
influence the families and the children
are actually going to say these are the
problems that we're having to the
advocate they're actually going to do
data tracking to say okay darlene
gildersleeve from hopkinton new
hampshire had two different child
children that were denied educational
evaluations she had two different
children that were denied their fair and
appropriate public education which is
also known as fate under the federal law
there they're also going to be told that
i mean we have another bill right now sb
394 in
hb1513
that darlene gilder steve's son was
kicked out of school and kicked off his
iep when he was 21 so he couldn't
graduate high school and the mom had me
i had to go and beg a charter school to
take him so the differences with this
advocate is families and children are
actually going to be heard and listened
to and put first
that that's going to be the buying
difference and keeping the office
separate is the key
because that's how we guarantee that
yes you may so in the in the example you
gave i mean when you say that that the
the office of child advocate is going to
be
uh for the for special education is is
going to be is going to receive the
complaint i mean isn't
isn't it the situation that
they're going to they're going to get
the complaint and they're going to say
you know mr x or ms ms x has complained
that their child was
was for lack of a better term
not properly treated in some respect
aren't they going to also
call the other side aren't they going to
call the school and say well wait a
minute that's what
this person claims is that true or not
there's actually going to be proof the
family keeps their own records
there like senator regan said
files of exactly what happened files and
files and files binders and binders of
complaints then we get trends we get
data tracking and then this child
advocate will work of special ed will
work collaboratively with commissioner
edelblut and the governor and not try to
write reports attacking them but say
listen
we're going to do these are the this is
what we're going to do and these are the
solutions and listen to the families of
the children who are experts in our
children with our medical professionals
and our reports and our records and all
of our experience
then we could say this is the real story
we're not going to let the lobbyists
speak for the school districts anymore
at three to five hundred dollars an hour
the parents and the families are going
to be hurt
okay
did you have a follow-up no no i but
okay maybe
yep let me get representative edwards a
turn thank you so much i appreciate it
okay no problem
representative edwards
i will comply okay and if you don't you
know that i will tell you that yes ma'am
i'm looking forward to avoiding that
okay thank you so so i'm representative
jess edwards auburn chester and sandown
also a member of the finance committee i
i i wasn't part of this bill
until very recently i got involved
because i had a large number of people
contacting me my background includes
being a manpower officer in the army
in which i i did manpower analysis and
organizational redesign and design on a
number of occasions so just to address
your question
should
this office be
co-located within the existing office or
should it become a separate independent
office the kind of factors that you
would look at in order to help make that
decision would be
is is the mission aligned are the two
missions aligned well enough to where
the central leadership of that
organization would be able to
parse out
what kind of support is needed for each
of the missions that's one aspect
is is it um a case where
um there there may be sort of um a
natural
motivation to focus on one side of the
mission at the detriment of the other
and if that exists
uh by
paying short shrift to the other side of
the mission
uh does that do some substantial harm
and then there's just another issue of
just workload i mean if if if we didn't
have to worry about
specializations of missions
prioritization of organizations
uh and workload
the entire federal government would be
one department
you know but but because we care about
these things we we tend to uh segregate
and segment
uh listening to the arguments um from
the representatives and senators that
looked at this i think they came to the
conclusion
that just as a matter of policy there is
good cause to me to establish this
office in a separate and distinct way
to representative lin's question about
well if we create a new office will they
be as feckless as we perceive the others
to have been and i i would say
that
we need to keep distinct the the
difference between
an organizational design
in the and the personnel that are used
to staff it
um
uh i i once had a senior boss basically
just rip up my plan for a reorganization
because he said this is all about people
if you don't if you don't have the right
people
in the right spot
it doesn't matter
what kind of design you have so so as
important as that is it's a distinct
thing from
how you design it to begin with
so um
so just i if it i it sounds like it
should become a separate office and that
it should be
the higher the new hire should be really
good um so that's that's those are my
are there any questions for
representative edwards
sure go ahead thank you madam chair
thank you for taking the question so i
understood everything you said is it
your position that you believe that the
uh representative
i
i i tend to have an opinion on
everything i i try to
highlight the ones that i really think
i've done my homework on and really or
have reached a conclusion
uh i i this one i'm sort of still
gelling
i i i think i'm 80 percent confident
that keeping them separate uh or
establishing an independent office to
advocacy for education that that is
probably a good idea
but i i i i can't swear it to you
[Music]
so so am i
hearing you right that although you're
straddling the fence a little bit most
of your body's on one side of it on the
leaning towards segregating the
i'm just trying to get it clear
yes sir 80 of my body is on one side of
the fence and that that's a lot of body
so
okay thank you
unless there were other questions no
okay
all right
um
should we bring the microphone to you
okay i think he turned the microphone
off so just press the little squiggly
button there
thank you
hi my name is jennifer pike i'm from new
london and i have a 17 year old son with
autism
and i'm not going to tell my story
thank you
um but i would like to talk a little bit
about um
the
requirements for
the soffit the office no well no no well
or
what you have
the offices should be separate thank you
um
because
it goes beyond
just um
special ed law experience
not only do they need
it's a very unique
position
they need special education
experience
they need to know
about disability
you know the disability world they need
they need to understand
you know the iep process in itself
is
an entirely different language
i do have printouts for you
for
that includes all of the acronyms for
special ed
which
i think that you would it's 11 pages i
think long
so
i just thought it would give you an idea
of i mean it takes a long time to learn
that language
so when you're a new parent going into
that world it
it's quite overwhelming and you
you really don't know i mean the school
district has
power over you because you really don't
know what people are saying to you
so and so when i when i
i know so sorry but when i hear that
um ms sanchez doesn't have any
experience in special ed
that's very concerning
because um
you know obviously she would be
overseeing
the person in her office
and
you know she would be
it would be very concerning
um
this person would also need to have um
you know experience with medical
diagnoses because they would be
overseeing and reading reports
they need to understand assessments they
under
so what you're saying is is that if i if
i could just kind of
get us back
is that
you feel
you believe that
the
person that the governor selects with
all of these criteria
would be better off in their own office
i do um i think that it is
it is just
an enormous position
um
in itself
the other concern that i have is that ms
sanchez testified
um
last week that
if there were
problems to arise that she would
uh
go to the department of ed and to pick
and
the whole point was to flush out
problems
and you know
independent of those
entities so
you know those we were trying to
be independent of that so
that was
that's okay thank you
are there any questions
seeing none thank you
mickey has provided uh oh
with the not yet
with the amendment
and um
i think that uh
i'd like to recess until
like one o'clock or a little after
to give us
an opportunity
to
digest all of this
and um
we'll come back at that time and make
make a decision yes ms sanchez
i'm wondering if i can respond
unfortunately i'm not available to come
back at one o'clock as much as i would
love to be able to be back here okay
so just a couple of points um to clarify
and and notes that i took from
those that that spoke after me
um i would like to note that we do
currently have staff in the office
that track data and trends for our
office for whatever we are looking for
data trends at that point um so do we
have the capacity in the office already
to track data trends in education if we
are getting complaints in regards to
education yes we do
we're not getting complaints with
education right now because we're not
known as i had noted earlier but if we
were known and understood to families
that we also worked in that capacity i
do feel that we have the capacity in the
office to track those trends and the
specialists that we would be looking for
would be then to take a look at those
trends and see what recommendations will
be made from that
um also i would like to note that i have
i'm hearing that there are parents in
the room who have children with autism
autism spectrum diagnosis that falls
under children's behavioral health we
already work in the scope of children's
behavioral health we work very closely
with that and again like i said when
we're looking at the holistic view of
the child
education is one piece of that and of
course special education is extremely
important and access to services for
children with autism spectrum disorder
services in school are extremely
important and we understand that in the
office so having that specialist to work
on that at the special education aspect
would only enhance what we are already
doing on the child behavioral health
side in regards to those diagnoses
and then i would like to just note for
the room that i by no means would call
myself a specialist in in special
education i take nothing away from these
families who work very very hard to get
their children to where they are
have i been able to experience special
education in the state of massachusetts
where i come from yes i have i've
interacted with that system quite a bit
i've seen some great things that the
system's doing i've seen some flaws in
that system as well and my hope would be
with bringing the specialist in the
office would possibly be able to bring
some of my experience from state that is
doing some things well in special
education and advocate for that here in
the state of new hampshire
thank you i'm sorry you won't be able to
come back i'm sorry as well it's that's
fine we
let's make it 115
okay
so we'll
see you then and um we're not going to
take any more
comments we're just gonna
go with the
what we're gonna do with the amendment
i'll call the meeting to order
the one handed out earlier i did i i'm
okay
i know but
in this one
yes
i talked to senator um reagan downstairs
um he asked me to relay he's got a some
other meeting right now but that um the
amendment is okay what he thought was
missing um is um in the bill so
everything oh okay so this is fine this
is fine
okay
thank you it's possible just piecing
this together i know there was a
conversation about the governor
appointing that's already in the
underlying bill which is why it wasn't
in the amendment yeah okay yep okay
all right well when he told me that i
thought hmm okay
all right so as long as this one's fine
okay
could i have a
motion on
amendment two zero two two
one eight five seven
thank you
ought to pass
yeah okay do i have a second
second thank you hang on one second nope
we're doing the amendment we're just
getting ready
all right
sorry about that
all those in favor
please raise your hand
unanimous
thank you okay now i will take an otp 57
a on
um
381 if i can find it
maybe it's right here and i just don't
see it
okay
yeah
okay otpa
thank you
do i have a second
all right is there any discussion
uh
let me just say this okay
uh obviously i'm gonna vote otpa okay
that's
neither here nor there
but
i do think that um the education
committee
needs to re-look at this
in a couple of years to see how
effective
this organization is
it is standalone
it's going to take some time for the
governor to appoint somebody
this lady here seemed really efficient
and
knew exactly what needed to be done but
i'm not sure whether the governor will
appoint her
but um you know i i do think that it's
essential
that
whatever services we provide for
children
are comprehensive
and that
we need to be sure
that
that's what they're getting
yeah right yeah and
well
oh yes go ahead please again just um
yeah i concur i think i mean they're two
distinct populations i think that
ideally looking um
at a comprehensive advocacy program
is probably a good idea down the road
but it seems like there's need for this
now
um i think there's probably going to be
hiccups in trying to figure out who and
how this is going to work out
but um i certainly support the attempt
to try it and appreciate that are there
two populations that need to be
addressed
okay thank you
are we ready okay go ahead i need to
make a comment i'm i i'm obviously going
to vote in favor of this also and i
guess what i
what i just say is i i completely agree
that that
it makes because of the differences on
on the on the type of
work that they're doing that it makes
and that that there's a good argument
for not having
them housed in the same
in the same uh office so to speak even
though maybe
man it from a managerial standpoint that
might be less somewhat less efficient
um
the the
the
real concern i have with with this but
i'm willing to let you know let's give
it a try and see how it goes i think
it's the the the
the uh
the the analysis is still out in my view
even on the office of child advocate is
whether
these things really work
you know because the theory is of this
of all of this stuff seems to be well
the school districts aren't really doing
their job with special education or the
dhhs isn't really doing its job with
providing
appropriate services to children and
therefore you need another agency to
sort of being be looking at them
i'm
skeptical about i don't mean don't get
me wrong i don't mean to say for by any
stretch that there aren't mistakes made
in both schools and in the dhhs but that
there's sort of a systematic problem
i am skeptical about that and whether or
not this will actually
if they're
whether there is number one and number
two if there is that this will
that this will solve it um and what i'm
worried about is in four or five years
there'll be a move for another agency to
look over this agency um but anyway
[Laughter]
representative heath we all agree with
yes
representative murray yes representative
umber yes
i'm sure the vote is seven to zero in
the affirmative okay the vote is 7-0 in
the affirmative so
uh joe you're writing the um
okay
all right um
we passed earlier today
um
with
uh representative turcotte and reps and
lynn not here but basically it was
simply um
a redo of all the things that we've
talked about
yesterday so
yes you put it all like in one amendment
yes we put it all in one amendment so
all right um
i will write the blurb on that one
unless somebody else wants to jump up
and do it
okay
um
sb
420.
oh ok the extraordinary needs grant
did you say you were gonna do that one
yeah
oh wait wait a second
okay
yeah did you send them to janna as well
all right i didn't you know but wait i
did i did the two i just i just sent it
directly to janet did you want that's
fine no okay no
what did you do i i did 346 and um
i did the minority report oh
okay so you did 346 346 yeah okay
last night
okay
right
so um
here's kind of my plan for
as we know
if we wait uh
at the executive session if we wait
until we get through all the bills then
it's going to be six o'clock
and then janet has two hours worth of
work
so what i'm planning to do is after each
division
um
completes their bills i'm going to take
a 10 minute recess
janet
to forward those
to
the clerk
okay so that the
the last one will be division three
and
i know that obviously
i have
a i have a blurb to write
and um
[Music]
represent petrie's finishing
his new one up
and
represent turcotte
has his to do so
okay
is there anything else
mickey do you have anything for us
no i think we're i think we're good you
think we're good i think we're good
okay
we'll see you
some of you at 215 and some of you at
no that's not for you tom
unless you want to become a republican
that's the other option come on
then
then you can then you can join our
caucus so
oh i guess i better uh
no
okay so let me go right my blurb
okay it's probably right in here
don't
oh